[Music]
i love music
i'm sure many of you do as well and it
occurred to me the other day that i
don't really listen properly to the
lyrics of some of my favorite songs i
don't appreciate the poetry of the
lyrics so i thought i'd take the time to
do that right now these are the lyrics
to one of my favorites
who let the dogs out last year in the
dance you had a ball you call me
millerbug and skettel get back fluffy
back scruffy get back you flee infested
mongrel if i was a dog the party is on i
got to get my groove on because my mind
done gone
can't you see the rays coming from my
eyes walking through the place like
digimon
breaking it down me and my white tail
short coat can't see color any color
will do i'll stick on you that's why
they call me pitbull because i'm the man
of the land when they see me they say
ooh
who let the dogs out woof woof woof woof
woof who let the dogs out woof woof woof
woof woof who let the dogs out woof woof
woof woof woof who let the dogs out
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
from wondering this life is short i'm
your host justin long
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
and as always i'm here with my brother
christian hi justin do you get
self-conscious about how you
greet me there very much so yeah i
thought you know
there you just said hi and i can also
tell when you're self-conscious let's
try one more time okay um
i'm your host justin long and as always
i'm here with my brother christian oh
hey what's up well that was a cool one
yeah
that was a whole different thing
couldn't be bothered
i'll tell you who's not self-conscious
um our guest today wolfgang puck and
that song that i just wrote the lyrics
to who let the dogs out woof woof woof
um always reminds me of of our guest
wolfgang puck not because of the woof
woof woof part but because i i just
always assume that wolfgang puck is a
huge baja man fan i do too i
i assume he he likes their whole catalog
not just their big hit you know well he
likes he's into the b-sides too the
b-sides you know that they've been a
band since 1977 i know
it's crazy i've also never heard you
sound whiter than me than when you read
those lyrics that says a lot you were
like you were like gleaming white you
know you missed you weren't around for
this but this may have rivaled that
moment i met one of the migos's migos
miga me
well they're the amigo i met amigo
one of the amigos
quavo
he was so cool i mean duh he's amigos
he's amigo of course he's cool
i can't even say the name of who he is
but he was really cool i felt um i felt
pretty white around him not as cool as
the baja men though what is your
favorite baja men tune um i god there's
so many to choose i it's hard for me to
just pick one i like uh hiro kitty kitty
meow meow
did someone leave the hamster cage open
[Laughter]
another classic is oh i forgot the poo
bags for my doggy
you know i think it's kind of sexist
that i've and because they've been
around so long and they've gone through
so many changes i wonder if they will
allow baja women
into their group
they should you know
um i hope they're listening
but yeah wolfgang that's always been a
name that i've had a hard time saying
wolf you still have a hard time i know
you're not saying it right well the
animal the wolf a wolf you can't get
that for some reason you have a hard
time getting the l in there a wolf the
timberwolves wolves
you guys can't see this but justin's
whole face is contorting when i can't
say something i get a little [ __ ] in
the face when i have a hard time
formulating a sound of a word you
remember what you couldn't say that time
you were um sugar cookie yeah christian
was drunk once and he couldn't say
the word sugar cookie
sugar he was like sugar cookie that is a
litmus test for all you listeners if
you're feeling drunk
that's how you know you're drunk if you
can't say sugar cookie it's true
articulately it's the sugar cookie test
sugar cookie so wolfgang puck i think we
should apologize to him for not giving
him a more respectful introduction
because
he is a man who is so deserving of yes
that's true our respect uh he everyone's
respected because everyone likes food
everyone know first of all everyone
knows him i think um
he might yeah is he the most famous chef
in the world he's one of the more
everyone knows wolfgang puck who's more
ubiquitous a chef than wolfgang puck
chef boyard i mean he's not a real chef
though chef julia childs but i think
wolfgang puck
especially now that he's branded himself
the way he has i think everyone knows
him and yeah and we were
so excited to meet him he's our first
non-entertainer guest that we've had on
the show that's right and we were just
excited that he wanted to do it we
couldn't be thrilled his son byron who
we i have to give a shout out to byron
knew who i was and i think kind of
confirmed to his dad that he should be
doing it so otherwise i don't know that
we would have gotten him so thank you so
much byron he showed up he was dressed
like a chef i don't know what i expect
him to be dressed like a bar man
[Laughter]
he was dressed like a chef but it is
weird he was dressed like a chef it was
also the middle of the day well he might
have been going right to the restaurant
i didn't want to i didn't want to pry
but i assumed or maybe he just always
dresses like a chef oh he's like he's
like chef pajamas he's like batman he
just goes through his closet it's just
all chef outfits yeah chef workout
clothes
um
but he had a very puckish energy would
you agree yeah absolutely i think i
mentioned that to him i mean the word
puck is you know midsummer night's dream
he seemed like he had a scampi playful
buoyant energy
he did have a puckish energy i i shook
his hand and i've had this experience
only a couple times where i shake
someone's hand
and i feel
um
sort of enthralled by what i'm touching
because i know that that hand or those
hands
are
capable of
of such yeah incredible creation it's i
think shaking ahead of a great musician
yeah you feel like these hands are so
special and they can do such amazing
things that's almost divine i almost
don't want to sully them with by
touching by gripping it too hard or or
ruining it something with your like
luddite kind of like clumsy hands um
puckish
meat puckish i mean a playful especially
in a mischievous way the synonyms are
funny
mischievous naughty impish elfin rogish
play eats
maybe not naughty well you know
we don't know stay tuned yeah
maybe he is
uh pixia she was not pixie but he was
pixie-ish for a man he was very kind we
had a very uh long and forthcoming
honest conversation with him which um i
was so pleasantly surprised by
hopefully you guys will be too so we'll
be right back after this with chef
wolfgang
sweetheart
hello
have you done this before sure i did a
lot of radio things but yes yeah
podcast is a new new thing yeah what's
new for me too um i my mother is a is a
uh great cook so i grew up i was very
lucky growing up uh with good food and
it's always been something that's very
important to me and uh great a pleasure
that i've
really enjoyed um
did you grow up with you you know i grew
up with great parents a great mother my
father was like a terrorist but my
mother was an amazing cook he was an
actual terrorist no doctor he terrorized
the family oh god of course he wasn't
there yes
before terrorists were really known but
i think
but my mother was amazing and the great
cook she was a professional chef too and
worked in a resort hotel in the
summertime in austria
austria yeah and in the wintertime she
was at home so
with very little money she made very
good food like we had meat once a week
oh once a week yeah on sunday lunch we
had meat we had wienerschnitzel or
something like that oh yeah and that's
was that your favorite so those are
yours
tell my childhood favorites and i
actually put them on a menu at spago and
beverly hills when we opened in beverly
hills uh 25 years ago was your mother
able to be a part of that yeah totally
wow so
uh
and it became such a huge success now i
can't take it off the menu oh yeah it's
been the same um and you moved to the us
then when you were 24 you're you're no i
came from i left austria when i was 17 i
moved to france
seven years in france and then i moved
to the us and is that that's where you
train then in france in france and in
austria i left school when i was 14. i
never went to high school yeah oh my god
and then uh
i started the apprenticeship from 14 to
17 and then i moved to france and worked
in some of the greatest restaurants like
in paris hotel de paris monaco and la
receiver
and so forth so you just had an aptitude
for you you had a gift for it at an
early age yeah i had a passion for it
and i really think when i went to south
of france
in a restaurant called bomania the owner
i was 70 years old but he was so
passionate about food and hospitality
and i said i want to be like this guy uh
oh and look at you now yeah i i wish he
could see you now
i know now you've seen you strike me as
somebody whose passion has not abated at
all you you strike me as still very
passionate about food is is is that safe
to say or do you feel yourself kind of
slowing down you know what uh it's so
funny because i always was worried
because i saw when i was young old chefs
they went into retirement and even i
said surely yeah they don't have nothing
to do anymore and i said hopefully i
don't gonna end up that way i said if i
retire i want to find a new passion yes
and i think sengan
i liked my old passion the most so i
never changed and i think we still open
new restaurants you know we're gonna do
this hotel down on sunset here in the
pantry hotel we can open a restaurant
there wow we are planning one with frank
gehry where gladstone is now on the
beach oh wow um what's but your first
the big one the the flagship was
sparkles and that is still thriving um
you you moved the restaurant at one
point in 97 what was that to be closer
to clientele no it didn't have nothing
to do but my lease was up up on sunset
almost and i tried to buy the building
and the owners didn't want to sell it
and i said i don't want to put so much
money into the building
and then it's not mine so
the pistol garden became available in
beverly hills and i said you know this
is a bigger property it has more room
for the kitchen and everything so i said
you know what i bought that place and
then uh moved spargo over there and
since 97 it has been a big success and i
have to be very proud of something
last year was the best year since we had
in set in 37 years no i wonder why do
you know what to do keep on getting
better every year are you going to be
more efficient maybe have more customers
because i always look at the customer
count and i said you know what it's
really an amazing thing that's amazing
after so much so many years we do better
than ever and in a city where you get
new restaurants all the time and
uh old restaurants fall by the way yeah
when i was here we had le dome we had
lauren sri we had mama's own we had
chase and the pistol the pistol garden
and listen
where are they now in the cemetery
yeah a delicious cemetery yeah so what
do you attribute that to is it the
desire to keep keep on pushing for us
and i think it has to be an evolution
yeah we can never stand still you know
we always have to continue
to get better and do more and how can we
be the best we can be so do you and you
obviously still cook there you're still
there yeah i know for sure i go all the
time in between cut which is at the
beverly worship and spago there one next
to the other and then i also have the
bellaire hotel which we took over seven
years ago that's right so you you make
the rounds yeah i make the rounds in
between all three of them as a matter of
fact at the belair hotel
people always ask me when we took it
over i a wolfgang why you don't make the
venus that's why you don't make
uh the kaiserschmann another austrian
dish from my mother's recipe and so i
had to put it on the menu there too and
now people go there especially for that
so it's really nice to see too yeah and
what a nice tribute to your mom yeah
she lives on into the food people loves
that's great but here when espargo was
considered a california cuisine so how
much of that was a departure from what
you've been doing in france it is
so i love the notion of regional cuisine
so in france when you were in normandy
in northern france you ate differently
they had cows they had this wonderful
pre-jesus they had a lot of butter and
things like that
in south of france there were no cows
there were olives old they had goats or
your uh
pigeons yeah maybe some wild stuff you
had olive oil and stuff like that and
great tomatoes great vegetables so
that's what we use there so i want to do
the same thing when i open spago i said
i want to really do what we have in
california in los angeles you have so
many different cultures so i use how
does that reflect so i wanted to have
the ingredients from here but reflecting
different cultures in my cooking style
so i started on making lobster sprinkles
so i started out making a baking style
duck so that i ate before this interview
yeah we started to make uh pizzas
because there's italian influences too
and some things maybe grilled i thought
because it's out of france and we had a
lot of girls there wood burning girls i
said i'm gonna build a wood burning
pizza oven and the wood burning grill
and keep the food simple but the highest
the highest quality i went every morning
to the fish market picked out the
freshest fish
served it in
spago like a sashimi for example
nobody had that on their menu in terms
of food i the only thing i can compare
to now in uh review-wise is is acting
and and i try to avoid
reading those reviews but i wonder that
the difference between a performance and
food strike strikes me as fast you know
like um if
food either tastes good and is
pleasurable to you or or it isn't yeah i
think i think for people to review this
so now it's different everybody is a
reviewer now they take pictures yeah yes
food was great how much does that change
things yeah
it has given the people in the newspaper
almost no power
yeah it's more democratic yeah it's
democratic and people have friends
they're different people they form
groups they chat about food they
uh hang out in certain restaurants my
son byron who is 24 years old
he doesn't go to the restaurants i go to
he hangs out with his friends in this
bars where they have cocktails and he
bites to eat does he try to encourage
you to go to those places yeah he
totally yeah yeah have you discovered
any good ones you know i am such a
creature of harvard so but i know
i have to look what's going on but i'm
listening to him a lot what's going on
like our new restaurant in washington
which we're going to open in washington
dc in georgetown a cut steakhouse also
but it's not only steak so we're going
to have more like a grazing thing and
like a steak see the cows yeah
yeah yeah they have a yard you can pick
out your own cow yeah um that would be
that's just food for thought yeah um i
actually went to school with uh zaggett
john johnson oh yeah
maybe a little bit oh yeah okay yeah he
used my refrigerator i had a little
mini fridge and uh the first day that i
met him uh
he said oh you mind if i
i said sure of course you uh you know
we're roommates we're friends now and
the next day was filled to the brim with
the most delicious food from from new
york i guess all the the chefs maybe you
included sent them feminists
yeah no i think it's great but it's good
to have young people because of that
they get really interested in food you
know it's annoying sometimes when they
take too many pictures or whatever
especially if it flushes with flush at
night but at the end what you think it's
it's better that way that people are
interested or would it be better if they
wouldn't care so i said you know what it
has some distractions but at the end of
the day i want people to get interested
however they're getting interested and
you're right it it seems i only recently
got really interested in cooking and i
think it's because
um i i've discovered the artistic value
the creative value yeah
it's such a great outlet and i think
even for me even if i cook at home for
my family oh you do yeah totally yeah
and uh does your wife my wife kalila is
a very good cook too but uh she makes
italia she's ethiopian so she makes
great ethiopian food
you know better have the injera and all
these dishes oh yeah but uh
she also cooks great italian food so
whenever she makes a lasagna or a pasta
polonies at home and she makes it from
scratch everything
and then if i make it at home and my
boys alexander and oliver will say papa
it's almost as good as mom's
so
that's funny is she has she ever given
any thought to opening her own
restaurant i think you know we have such
a big business together you know so we
don't want to separate it yeah and she
is really the director of branding and
everything to really tie everything
together which is not that easy because
we have things in supermarkets we serve
express
what is your favorite wolfgang puck
express well i like the pizza so if i go
to
gilson or something like that yeah all
right pizza because i want to try what
they do do they always recognize do they
offer no no never not no i really i put
on a baseball card and sunglasses oh my
god oh really and then you must look
like a criminal i know then they say oh
you sound like wolfgang puck
but i see that you're really just a an
undercover criminal yeah what inspired
you to to do that to take it to take
your
high-end cuisine and put it uh in in a
more affordable setting well i really
believe not
people don't gonna go every day to spago
or qatar to an upscale restaurant
sometimes you just wanna no not even not
even you wanna stay at home watch a
movie that's true so if you can
have them now especially deliver the
good pizza like from girls and wolfgang
puck pizza
and all you do is pop it in the oven and
that's it it's so funny it's how
different people are like when i did
their oscars three years ago or two
years ago when jennifer lawrence won an
oscar for best actress i think yes and
so when she walked into the
uh ballroom where we do the big dinner
she i think was with her agent and i
said hello congratulations
jennifer and then she pushed the guy
next to her and said who is that
and
he said it's wolfgang puck you don't
know
she said oh my god i have him on my
canned soup at home i see him every day
it's like meeting chef boyardee i know
in the flesh
oh it's a real person that's really
funny um you went from being this this
great uh well-respected chef for many
years to somebody that everybody started
to know except for jennifer lawrence
apparently yeah but everybody even even
she saw you on on the cans
was that because of the oscars because
of your involvement at the governor's
ball um when you when you started
cooking there what was the tipping point
for you well i think the tipping point
in the old time for example johnny
carlson was one of our best customers
uh-huh and
he used to come in the 80s mid 80s or so
to spargo here on sunset boulevard
and then sometimes on friday he said
wolfgang can you make me 10 pizzas to go
i love those pinches and yeah the
smaller the better that's it yeah
i'll work on it i'll workshop it okay
so he would order drinks so he ordered a
pizza and one day i asked him johnny
what you're doing with 10 pizzas you're
gonna have a party tonight
he says no i put him in the freezer and
when i play cards with my friends we get
hungry at two in the morning and we have
the pizza i was upset though everyone
said i don't want to give you the pizzas
anymore and then i said maybe i should
just try them out and see what it is
when it's frozen because you're you
because you were thinking how that that
you can't freeze pizza yeah how dare you
my pizza yes
that's
i cooked one
and then
i took it home put it in the freezer
i took it out i cooked it i said you
know maybe i cooked it too long at spago
i'm gonna cook it a little bit less
so i cooked one halfway only
and then put it in the freezer and then
took it out and you know what the dough
was nice and crispy underneath it was
actually very good i said you know if
you give me a pizza at spago or you give
me this one i wouldn't know the
difference really yeah so you tested it
yourself and it was all thanks to johnny
carson yeah so i got into the frozen
pizza business because of johnny no
kidding he didn't need any royalties so
it was okay yeah that's the nicest part
he made enough money did he tease you
about getting royalty yeah he said
sometimes okay now you have this
gonna get something yeah yeah
and um and so in terms of being known
did you go on johnny's show did you
start i did his show once yeah only uh
but i think uh
i decided to do leatherman show in new
york oh right
when he was right after johnny carson at
that time and so is that fun for you to
do those things i was very nervous at
the beginning especially with david
letterman and johnny for sure too yeah
uh michelle i know less
yeah but i think uh
i don't know i did yeah
i don't intimidate you no um
yeah it is it's it's a strange thing and
i can imagine as a for someone who says
oh yeah you're gonna imitate
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men valued for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
your name is your stepfather's name
right you puck yeah pakis my
stepfather's name so and my mother had
me
and then uh with this guy
he couldn't marry her because my mother
was a bouquet you know
my mother wasn't rich but my father was
actually very well-off okay i mean uh he
drove a mercedes he owned restaurants he
owned a big farm this is right after
world war ii yeah after world war ii so
he already drove a mercedes at that time
and everything so and i'm sorry what did
he do he evo had he owned in a small
town the butcher shop a gust house a
small hotel wow outside a lot of forests
you know they want a lot of land so so
he was really well off
but then his mother said if you marry
this poor girl
you know i'm gonna give everything to
your brother the younger ones wow you
know at that time it was like you had to
marry somebody yeah your same class same
class yeah
so he took a chance he must have really
loved her yeah maybe i mean i i know but
not enough yeah
or maybe he resented her
you know because you know you know who
knows what happened i only met him once
oh really yeah oh so so they split or so
they split up
and then my mother found this crazy guy
named joseph
in a home or just no no no i don't know
where i didn't ask her where but you
know it's in a village they knew he was
their families he was the village crazy
man the crazy guy but he was very into
sports he was a boxer and everything
and his name was park buck yeah what was
his first name joseph joseph park it's a
great it also fits you so well you you
have a puckish energy
when i started at 14 after one month on
the job
the chef told me you're good for not
saying go back home oh really yeah so
what was his name let's give him a
little shout out
no he's sad his dad oh good good he was
as bad as my stepfather my stepfather
always told me you're good for nothing
you're good for nothing
i thought it was your father who was no
my father you know you only met once
yeah so the stepfather was there
oh my gosh so he really was quite crazy
great totally crazy yeah when i look at
him he used to beat me up and now oh my
god so was that part of your impetus for
wanting to get out of the house yeah
totally so when i was 14 i left my house
oh my god i moved 50 miles away your
poor mother was left there with him yeah
with him and my
two sisters and my brother who was just
born oh my god did you did you ever send
for them or did you ever no so then
i went there and then i went even
farther i went to france
and i i was so pissed off and i never
wrote that they didn't know where i was
for one and a half years wow and uh so
one day
uh one of the dishwasher or one of the
guys in the restaurant i worked in south
of france came to me and says you know i
just here on the radio radio they were
looking for you
uh your family and you should contact
the australian embassy
wow so then i said what they want the
embassy for what
and so i went to the post office i had
to call the embassy and said you know
my name is so-and-so and uh i heard
somebody's looking for me oh my gosh
and they said yes it's your parents you
better send them a note and uh and do
something
and i said okay better i better write
for my mother for a year and a half she
didn't know if i was dead or alive oh my
god so you never even said to her i'm
mad you never i told you i'm going to
france that was it okay so she knew that
you would have i was in france but she
then she didn't hear nothing for a year
and a half so you know my god i can see
i have children if i might imagine yeah
say i'm moving to europe and then now i
couldn't call them like they didn't
write i don't know where they are
on instagram or something yeah just know
i know now it's easy back then it was
only my space i know so um so you must
have been a fairly tough kid no you know
what i was tough but i was very scared
especially when my
the chef you know and my father told my
stepfather said you know you're going to
be back in
in a month but
nothing he made you feel really small
yeah really small and when i left he
said oh you're good for nothing you're
gonna come back you're gonna ask me for
money and you know trying to put me down
i said i'm never coming home so then
and months into
being uh in the restaurant i was 14 and
i was like five foot tall you know
really tiny yeah and then i was peeling
potatoes and washing spinach and doing
all cleaning the kitchen
and then on sunday at lunchtime we
ran out of mashed potatoes we ran out of
potatoes and regular potatoes and
everything and then at the end it was
all my fault i didn't even know how much
they needed so the chef calls me over
and says ah you're good for nothing you
better go back home to your mother oh
god i like crushing so crushed i know so
that was probably my worst time so that
evening
i went uh over the big bridge and i said
i'm gonna jump in the river and kill
myself oh my god and uh i was standing
and standing up there like for an hour
and
thinking but it would be
dead if there's a heaven or if there's a
hell or things like you know as a kid
all this thing goes through your mind
even as an adult yeah
and then about an hour later i said you
know
i just gonna go back tomorrow morning
and see what happened maybe he gonna
forget or maybe he's going to change his
mind or whatever
so i go back the next more i didn't
sleep or not over here on the bridge
yeah wow wow thank god yeah and then i
went back and the apprentice who was
above me was happy to see me because if
not he would have to peel potatoes
yeah and then uh
uh
he hid me in the vegetable cellar we had
the cellar underneath the hot towel
because he knew that the head chef was
still so upset yeah well he knew also he
doesn't go down there so i was peeling
onions and potato in secret in secret
yeah
and then three weeks later the chef
comes down and sees me down says what
are you doing here and he tried to grab
me and pull me out i put dug my heels in
and i said i'm not going home
wow and he didn't know what to do he
screamed at me i said i'm not going home
oh my god and then finally he didn't
know what to do he called the owner of
the hotel who was running who was the
manager too and he says what should i do
with this kid you know and yelling and
he's good for nothing he's too young and
too little and on yeah
yeah
then the owner was nice and he sent me
to
his other had another little hotel there
and there they had a woman chef and he
wanted to get you away from this yeah
yeah and then uh she was nice she said
just be quiet and uh do your job and
everything would be fine and everything
ended up okay and then amazing i'll say
that's an understatement but but amazing
that just because the potato incident he
would be so irate it's like you reminded
him of somebody oh my yeah i said you
know what this is the reincarnation i go
away from my stepfather now i find
another crazy guy you can't avoid him
well and naturally afterwards both of
them
sought because of them i became
successful of course you know my product
used to come to spago and says ah if i
would have been just like all the other
fathers around you know
you would have ended up somewhere
being nothing how
angry does that make you did that make
you very it must have been frustrating
it's for years and years
i never wanted to go home to australia i
bet and to stay even to stay there yeah
so i have never spent
more
than a week maybe at the most in
australia but never more than a week or
even less
in my way i grew up really
and just because the association yeah i
got this crazy feeling over me and you
know i saw a psychiatrist for it years
ago and everything but it didn't go away
even if i talk about it now i can talk
about it but yeah you know it doesn't
make me feel comfortable when i go home
so the funniest thing is this year i'm
gonna go for 10 days really but with
your kids with uh my wife and my kids
too yeah and my kids gonna stay with my
sister
and uh uh my wife and myself gonna go to
this spa and the spa is next door to the
hotel where my mother used to work and
where i used to spend summers kidding
are you going to be able to see the home
you grew up in yeah yeah i'm going to go
see because my parents are both gone you
know but my sister lives in the same
house and i always tell my sister how
can you live in the house yeah what did
she say she said i love it i love it
okay he was abusive to her
also yeah oh my god you know it may be
quite therapeutic for you to revisit
that and to kind of like i mean
obviously you love food you have a
passion for it it's food but
deeper than that how much of it do you
think is like
hey
[ __ ] you dad step dad you know i mean
like look what i've done you know in the
old time i now i don't think anymore
about that but in the old time i
remember when i left
from america
and i told him i'm not coming back until
i have a mercedes and i'm going to drive
it through the front door
into the living room of the house did
you actually buy a mercedes when you you
know then i had a mercedes and i sent it
to my sister in australia
school teacher school principal wow um
so that's amazing that you were able to
do that and and then and that your
mother uh was able to see you yeah no i
think for my mother it was really
special to see me successful yeah
parents i remember when my mother came
over with with my stepfather too and uh
what is that like i think in 1983 or 84
when they came i bought them first to
new york and then we went to washington
at that time reagan was president
and i mo i knew mike diva very well so i
called up mike and said you know can we
come and visit the white house and he
says yeah why you don't come home and
have lunch with us oh my god so you know
how great and then we had lunch there
and nancy came by and said hello and
everything and she of course she knew
you at that point because at that point
yeah yeah i know mommy's on yeah i
haven't known for mommy zone that was
something i mean everyone must have gone
in there do you i'm guessing arnold
schwarzenegger eats there at least
a couple times yeah not now since he's
divorced not as much oh okay okay he
does the wolf king express yeah
but i think i think everybody especially
the older people i love like i've become
very good friends with billy wilder oh
wow you know
australia
and even older than that like with
awesome wells i mean some of the giants
really yeah he must have eaten a lot
yeah totally totally yeah yeah you must
have fed him well so i think i think i
really had an affection for these people
you know why i wonder why i don't know
you know in a way you yourself have a
lot of acting credits
yeah but not good one no did you ever
harbor
sometimes i do and many times i say no
no because i said i don't want to be
known as a bad actor
you know i'm not sure it's a good
challenge let me tell you how it feels
i don't know
i think [ __ ] this much better or perfect
and what are you looking to do next is
there is there a culinary world you
haven't explored that
there's always an evolution you know we
don't want to change the world in one
day or do something totally different
totally new no
i like the food has to taste good that's
first you know just to play around with
all these chemicals and whatever a lot
of young people do today
it doesn't mean anything unless you want
to go back and eat it again you know
just a newness wears off really yes yeah
novelty to me cooking is about great
products you know if you start with the
best products and then don't [ __ ] it up
and you're done yeah that's maybe why
you had such a you focused on local yeah
ingredients and even still today i like
to go i like to go to the fish market i
like to go to the farmers market yeah i
if you say wolfgang why you don't go
shopping you need a new suit i hate it
no oh really clothes and stuff like that
doesn't it yeah you don't value that
stuff no but but so that's what i love
about the movie giro dreams of sushi i
love watching i love the parts where you
watch him pick out the ingredients so
that you know it's an interesting thing
because this created a whole new genre
for netflix yes
shows yeah uh chef's table yeah they are
doing a movie about me too
not just chef's table but
one hour one hour and a half life story
oh great so that's something that you
had to sit for and yeah you were
interviewed for is is that embarrassing
at all do you get it no not anymore now
because i really tell the story now the
way it was before i blocked it all out
but now why why because your family i
don't know maybe because of the family
maybe maybe it was embarrassing to me
and
i think but now i want
young people to know you know adversity
sometimes is not a bad thing and you
know i didn't come from a rich family i
didn't come i didn't have any penny when
i came to america
but if you work hard you have some
talent you can achieve a lot you know
what three years ago or so the wall
street journal did an article on me
and the
end of the question the last question
was so what is your dream
and you know i never went to high school
to college nothing i said my dream would
be to go to harvard oh really so five
days later the dean of the business
school comes calls me and says when you
want to come to harvard isn't that great
now you get an honorary degree yeah so
then i said i don't know i never went to
high school i never went to college i
don't even use a computer how can i go
to harvard he says no no we have the
right program for you and everything so
then anybody can go to harvard then two
years ago i started this program called
opm owner precedence management
and uh i did one month two years ago
last year one month in february and this
year in march like we graduated this
year end of march opm opm so you
graduated yeah opm sounds president's
management it sounds a little too much
like opium for me but
you know close enough
i didn't have to take any drugs in
college
well then you didn't really get it there
was too much to learn yeah but it was so
exciting because the professors there
like i became very friends with a guy
named boys roysberg he was so he's so
passionate just the
this must be exciting yeah it was a very
exciting time i learned so much so you
were able to graduate you know they did
they have a little ceremony i had my
whole family yeah ceremony there yeah so
i had my kids the younger one they must
have just been graduating from college
yeah my son bion graduate from uh uh
cornell last year oh wow my son kyle uh
cameron is working on his phd he's going
to be a professor
a phd phd in the history of physics so
he's gonna talk about his
science yeah he doesn't that's a she
doesn't have a brain that's true he's
not afraid to make money because if not
he would have chosen another thing but
he married very smartly because he
married a woman who also went to have a
business school oh wow but she works for
mckenzie consulting and they
make good money there well i'm so he's
off my payroll totally okay
so you have room for somebody well i
have two young ones
i hope they're working yeah um well i
like byron selfishly because he was
excited for you to do this um what did
they don't have accents at all do they
do they no not even they actually speak
english the proper way not like me no
not that they learned it from my wife
kalila because she has an ethiopian act
oh wow yeah and where did you guys meet
we met at at the restaurant oh okay most
of the people i meet at the right that's
right because you're always there yeah
i'm always there yeah and how many do
you have rest no not wives wrestling so
we have upscale restaurants 27. so um i
i in speaking of that you are you're
involved in multiple charities uh yeah
now was giving back uh you can you talk
a little bit about watching you know
already when i started spago in 1982 in
1883
i saw when i drove from melrose they had
this old folks home at that time they
sat outside all set and then i
i
heard about one of our customers was
doing meal deliveries for homebound
people and everything so at that time
aids was coming wrong so strong and you
know people threw their kids out their
sons out or whatever and uh and says you
know you have aids you know people
didn't know what it was and this is
something that you can probably at least
psychologically relate to yeah um
because you cannot accept that yeah you
know yeah especially when you're dealing
with
such high-end clientele you know and
there's so much privilege so you're
you grew up without you know my mother
had alzheimer's at the end
and so we raised a lot of money in las
vegas with larry oboe and we built this
big
alzheimer's research center one of the
top one in the world which is run by the
cleveland clinic so
hopefully
they figure that out one day too i hope
so i i hope um because there must be
nothing worse than seeing somebody that
you love go through that but it's also i
i i can't get past that that you grew up
without
much means
yes so you must feel
somewhat connected to people totally and
you know what it was amazing when i was
11 year old there is a
a
welfare thing like that a
charity group called save the children
but save the children
picked me and sent and 20 kids from our
region in austria and sent me once for
three months to london go to england oh
no kidding yeah when you were when i was
a kid really because they we'll save the
children still
an active organization yeah yeah yeah
yeah great yeah yeah so do you continue
you must support yeah yeah yeah enough
oh my god and they must know that now
that you yeah
when i told them that we did their
benefit like that at spago and they said
can you say a few words and i said you
know what i will say a few words but you
guys mean a lot to me because i never
went on my on vacation with my parents
you actually sent me to england when i
was a kid and that was the first time in
my life i had a vacation it was the
first time
i found corn flakes
and i i love them i usually do conflicts
with brown sugar and milk i used to love
it so i said a lot of things i learned
in england oh wow so you were a child
they saved yeah that's amazing
what other
guilty pleasures do you have that people
might be surprised by like twinkies or
no chocolate good chocolate it has to be
65 75 chocolate do all austrians love
chocolate is that a i think we grew up
on sweets a lot we used to have for
dinner like a noodles with uh sweet
noodles you know and a glass of milk
that was dinner or we used to have
crepes with marmalade inside and a glass
of milk that was dinner and as kids we
didn't really miss meat at all yeah my
parents didn't have a refrigerator at
home you know because you said you would
meet you were allowed me once a week
once a week my mother went to
town they had to walk like an hour
to the butcher shop and then uh buy
some
pork meat or whatever and then they made
miners
it was always good and we had a great
garden so everything came from the
garden do you still garden
garden like like the way
we talk now farm to table yes i grew up
like that when i was a kid something
special was a canned pineapple i i look
back at some of the meals my mom
prepared for lunch and i i cringed
thinking how little i appreciated them
because she would go through to such
lengths to
you know little healthy healthy lunches
and you wrap them all up and write a
little note
and and then i would trade
for you know twinkies and ho hos with
other kids this is like this crap i
really regret it yeah we had everything
homemade marmalade yeah we went in
marmalade we went in the forest picked
raspberries strawberries blueberries wow
brought them home and my mother cooked
them and made with the raspberries
raspberry juice so we had our own spring
at home so we had a bump and had to pump
out the water so cool it went like sweet
old lady marmalade yeah and we had the
best marmalade i loved it uh this is
maybe a strange question but but do you
use emojis on the phone do you have a
phone now only hats for my wife
oh man
that is the nicest answer we i asked
everyone that yeah that is easily the
nice right
or it's second to neil patrick harris
saying the eggplant with the
water coming out uh hearts to your wife
that's how you end text that texture is
really sweet um if you could be a
professional athlete what sport would
you play you think
if i today
i wanted to be like roger federer oh
yeah yeah because he has endorsements
makes a lot of money but
he is at his age still one of the tops
in the world this is you and with the
grace he moves makes it look so
effortless and everything and i love to
play tennis too
if you would have asked me as a young
kid
as kia in australia is key you know king
is the main sport now you're able to
take your i imagine you take your your
own family on vacation yeah we go up to
wales
that's amazing i'm so happy for you i i
oftentimes you meet successful people
people who have achieved a lot and it's
now here you are
years later you are doing that you are
you're doing what he did and i'm sure
there are young chefs observing you
walking in with
de niro and yeah and i think i'm giving
a commencement speech up in the culinary
school up in pasadena
uh why because i want to tell the young
people who go through that that you know
what even you have adversity you can go
through it and don't use no for an
answer you can do it yeah yeah and
there's a lot of i mean yeah um
who do you ever get starstruck around
people now when you because you've met
everyone i'm sure uh
i don't know i think i met almost
everybody in the world yeah you know i
used to sit with uh
gin kelly i used to play tennis with him
and sydney bought years they danced with
him but it's cool to see yeah i wouldn't
haven't touched that at all
like cinephone yesterday i got part of
my children you know so i met a lot of
these people and you know some of them
are not good and some of them are
amazing yeah some of you yeah so i think
but i met so many amazing people but you
probably see them all as like you you
know them in in such an informal way
that they probably just all yeah it's
totally totally easy you sit down with
them hang out with them and talk to them
do you enjoy that part of your for sure
i really think that is an important part
in my life to go out
talk to people welcome them to our
restaurant and you know because i think
people come to our place and they pay
it's like but for me it's like my home
yeah yeah so if you invite friends over
to your house or people you business
people whatever they are you're going to
say hello to them and please say welcome
to my house here you know look at that i
have great artwork or i make good food
whatever yes of course you're going to
be in yeah you're going to embrace it so
that way i think people and myself we
have a connection then yeah and i think
to me to connect with people is an
important part and food there's a few
things that are more intimate
exactly so nothing better than connect
with food i love this is a very selfish
question and and um i love asian food i
imagine i love soup dumplings
have you are you
what are some of your favorite just for
me what are some of your favorite uh
chinese asian cuisine uh i love so many
different things yeah probably if i
would have to pick one yeah would be
baking duck oh you love pegging i love
that i serve that at chinwat yeah yeah
and i modified it i serve it with the
plum sauce and i have different pancakes
and everything but
in every one of our restaurants i serve
it at spago oh really i told chef hugo
to serve it at the belair hotel
we're gonna start serving it at cut in
washington dc and in new york too as a
matter of fact when i opened shinoah i
had a whole duck menu ducks hate you
ducks don't like me no
they're not listening we're not
sponsored by are we oh we're almost done
uh
other than la where where would you want
to live because i know you've lived here
for a long time you know i lived in land
i love it here i think living in la is
great now better than ever i think it
has become a world-class city in art and
many different things you know
culinarily too
for sure and i think so the climate is
amazing you can live in a nice house
instead of living in an apartment
building on the 32nd floor yeah i think
it's really a great place to live
for chef we have great products here
when you get this i was just in new york
had cut and i said i should have bought
the strawberries from the farmer there's
a farmer in oxnard they're called
harry's berries
and i said you know it's a totally
different experience than when you get
them there really so we have so many
great ingredients here it makes it
really fun to cook because it all starts
with great ingredients but but i'm sure
you can find great ingredients there i
mean in the farms no but in the summer
yeah yeah for two months
you get the tomatoes for one month and
yeah the corn for one month and then the
strawberries and then it's over do you
have a garden at your house
you know i have a garden at the house
but i'm not a good gardener okay um
what about snack do you ever have like
guilty pleasure snack foods like combos
or doritos or no no never i feel sorry
as a matter of fact as a matter of fact
i don't like even my wife loves potato
chips like she brings potato chips to
the bedroom i said
i hate the smell of that i don't want
that wow i don't and i don't like peanut
butter really yeah i mean we never have
peanut butter at home my poor kids
uh-huh did you make their uh school
lunches ever did you ever yeah all the
time then they're really
as i can't imagine kind of so are you
making them sandwiches and stuff yeah
yeah i know with prosciutto arugula and
a little fresh mozzarella and olive oil
oliver when he went to the center for
early education at the beginning
so i used to make his lunch lunch
and like he used to love the rice and
the lobster from shinoahe so i always
ordered more and he used to take a
little box of chino our lobster with
them too
to the school and the beverly one of the
teachers said oliver if you don't want
to finish your lunch just tell me i will
finish it that's funny yeah i went to
spago once and there was a incredible
white truffle thing on the menu it was a
white truffle pasta
uh i'm sure you're familiar with it and
it was for a meeting with this is going
to sound very name-droppy but it was
joel silver and robert downey jr and his
wife and his robert robert's wife ran
joel's company and it was about a movie
that that has they wanted me to do and
and um i said oh my god and the waiter
told us about the white truffles special
this pasta and and i said oh my god
that's he said it's 150 and i said well
well
i made a big deal because when i was
growing up when we would go to
restaurants which was you know
maybe once every other week um once we
we we didn't get appetizers there were
limitations you know yeah i was not poor
by any means but it was uh so i thought
150 i can't do this and um
and chill chill silverside do you want
it do you want the pasta
and i said
well yeah but i can't and he's like get
he's getting the pasta and he got me
this pasta and i felt it was so
good i mean good it's not it's too small
but it was i couldn't but i couldn't
stop thinking about
these white truffles yeah how much it
was and i just regressed back to being a
kid and i felt so guilty but i will
never forget it was one of the most
pleasurable experiences of my life i
will never forget that um and i have you
to thank for that yeah you know i went
once to to i used to go to the truffle
auction in pierre monte in italy all the
time and i bought once one that must be
fun is that yeah i loved it you know you
heard oh it's like some people go to
painting or jewelry auction i went to
the truffle and there was one room like
twice the size is your room here in an
old castle where we had lunch and i
should point out this is a very small
room basically in a closet yeah
so it was maybe 25 20 the room or
something like that
and they had all this beautiful silver
platter with the white napkins and
different truffles bigger one small one
i bought the biggest one and that was
you know in the 90s for uh
nine eighteen thousand or nineteen
thousand dollars
and then i won one was two pounds oh my
god it was in the 90s yeah and then i
bought i brought it home
i brought it home and you know then i
put it in they gave me a nice wooden box
and i put another box around
with tape so what did you smell off what
did you call it no so then i come in
so go through custom
and all of a sudden they had the dog
there and the dog was smelling i didn't
declare it and nothing i said oh my [ __ ]
he is gonna they're gonna take my
truffle away and throw it down in the
garbage and i started to sweat and the
lady called me over a lady a police
officer called me over and says wolfgang
and she didn't say okay i said where
you're coming from i said oh i was in
milan i was cooking in dinner and you
know we
owned spago here and there's some we're
not talking talking i'll swear
okay
okay you go she let me go yeah but the
dog was sniffing around my bag i could
have kicked him i don't know
so from then on you had to
now
next year i i said okay i'm gonna
declare it you have to put it in a
lubricated condom yeah
um
what that's really funny that's really
funny because they would have right made
you throw it out i am totally 18 and
maybe give me a fine for not declaring
that's funny
well that now makes me think that 150
dollars for that because it was a steal
it's expensive yeah oh god yeah um even
the regular ones now this was an auction
and this this it's like a specimen this
this roughly was like that big you know
but it cost 4 000 a pound oh my god so
it's expensive and it's and and pigs
rooted out right
not pigs anymore dogs mostly dogs
because the pigs they grow
and then they have to snout you know and
they can dig because it's underneath the
earth like maybe that much 10 inches
underneath and the pigs can smell it
they have a very good nose but to hold
them back
it's very difficult they eat them yeah
so with the dogs you put them back and
you know they they go away but the pig
might have 200 pounds so that's why this
dog this drug sniffing dog was so eager
he was saying he was for other drugs
for dogs
um and and those drugs
i imagine um it would be hard to smoke
uh marijuana and do what you do that
would be very different i don't need
drugs i have good food isn't it
for me it's the best drug yeah but if
you could have dinner with three people
um whom you've never met uh
living or dead
wow there are too many to miss me i
think i would have a banquet and go from
one to the other listen to their stories
like i had i think you know of older
people maybe a writer like shakespeare
would be really interesting maybe a
brilliant mind like picasso would be
really interesting and then
music i mean when i just saw another
wolf bohemian yeah but also the modern
one yeah like i saw bohemian rhapsody
and i thought i love how you say that to
me it was an experience and i think the
guy
who played freddie was amazing mommy
malik incredible yeah i was incredible i
said you know what this was actually
good and i saw him
at the academy awards
and you know he i said oh you know i
love queen i said
uh he said you know in a song and i went
mama
you know i can't quit
he looked at me and says
stay in the kitchen
then he nudged his friend yeah who's
that he nudged jennifer lawrence yeah
who is that um
that that's fantastic um you uh
oh god there was oh i met henry kissin
met i saw henry kissinger once it was uh
i i was
drinking margaritas was the first time i
got really drunk on margaritas
and i'm not proud of this but i
uh i was at a party for uh it was after
that movie frida uh frida kahlo and it
was an after party for this movie and
henry kissinger happened to be there for
some reason and he was squirring two
really beautiful
statuesque women and he walked he kind
of like was gliding across the floor on
his way to the exit and um i wanted to
say something to him i don't know why
and i said henry mr kessinger
and i i go
and i got his attention he stopped and
he turned and looked at me and uh and i
said you're awesome
at diplomacy
and he
and he said thank you very much and he
kept walking you're awesome at diplomacy
i imagine your interaction with mr
kissinger was i used to sit with him he
used to come to fargo because he was on
the board of century fox yeah so he used
to come out here all the time you know
for board meetings and then he used to
come to spago for dinner and i used to
sit where they might be talk because we
talked both talk german so it was all
right of course yes that's good uh
scheissen
my dad is hopefully listening and speaks
german um
uh who do you know the muppets the the
show the muppets i heard about it yeah i
i am the worst the only i don't watch
much tv oh well you're so busy i'm busy
at night so i don't sit at home at night
watching tv i work i think i watch the
news i think for me it was great when
cnn came along a long time ago you could
watch news anytime not only at 11
o'clock or at uh at six o'clock yeah so
that was important and now
most of the movies i see on planes you
know we have restaurants so far way new
york in uh
london in the middle east so you spend
16 hours on a plane or in singapore i
mean it takes forever so i watched say a
movie i just watched uh uh
uh estar is born and i watched uh
bohemian rhapsody and uh i watched free
solo oh this week yeah yeah
in one yeah on the plane on your way to
uh orlando no no on my way to uh new
york yeah so what uh so and also you but
you see these people all the time yeah
i'm at that sometimes i don't know what
to do especially the young one
like i remember we did the oscars and uh
we were in the green room with my son
byron and then
my son says oh my god
look who is here
he was the main guy from black panther
chadwick boseman yes and and are you
tempted to just say uh what do you say
what do you have a standard uh lined
would you say good to see you it's yeah
hello it depends if i meet them at the
restaurant or something
do you have a good memory in terms of
meeting yeah yeah
a lot of people tell me how do you
remember how you remember i'm jealous i
am the worst um
i remember this i
remember also a lot of people i forget
people have their birthday party ten
years ago in a restaurant yeah well and
then they come back and says don't you
remember my my birthday party here
and they remembered every episode and
for a long time ago i still remember in
1984 we had the olympics here yes the
king of sweden with his wife came to
spago and five six other people they
were sitting next to the kitchen
i go out and give
the queen my cookbook sign my cookbook
for her and he grabs the book and says
uh no i cook at home
you know so i signed it to him too
good stuff i think was his name
and so then years later maybe i wouldn't
think a king would would do something
like that that's a few yeah but he was
great and i sat down with him and i'm
very single and then he says isn't there
a power club we can go to and i said
well i know this club next to next to
cedars-sinai there used to be a club
there i'm gonna hide and uh and then uh
i called them up
and i said uh
can we uh uh get i have the king of
sweden
but he wants to go to a club
the guy laughed at me and said [ __ ] it
you know
i have no table not for anybody their
joint is packed and i said okay even for
the king of sweden yeah so then we went
over to the beverly wilshire he stayed
there and they had a thing called
hernandez hideaway i ran in and i said
can we put the table together for eight
people and they they had part and i said
we already gave last course oh my god
and i said it's for the king of sweden
he said i don't care you probably don't
have that very often i'm sorry king
there's no right i know so i said oh i
think it's i just told him it's boring
you don't want to go in there and say
it's over you must go
home but then so about six years ago
we were in san tropez my friend has a
house next to the king of sweden and he
has the same birthday as me
so he does a birthday party and the king
of sweden he knows him you know
privately very well they always from
king stuff yeah so and uh
and uh
i see the cross from him from dinner
so and i told him that story
he looked at me and thought i was crazy
oh really yeah
he said you must be are you sure you
have the right key okay
maybe he's another scandinavian king
yeah um that's really funny uh if you if
you i'm guessing you don't but do you
have a vanity plate on your car a vanity
license plate no if you
had one
what would you say
i don't want to because then people know
who you are and i i much rather be
that's tough for me
i had a slight speech impediment as a
kid and wolf is the kind of okay god
hold on
[Music]
do you prefer uh the beatles or the
rolling stones rolling stones wow that
was the fastest i've ever heard anyone
answer that except someone in the
rolling stones um
uh and and
what do what would you want your epitaph
to read i don't want to be too dark but
uh
have you given any thought to something
like that
he was a good father yeah
that's a that's a really good answer i
think at the end that's the most
important thing really you know
businesses come and go yeah
you just are successful not so
successful everybody who is successful
had big failures too yeah look at our
president
i don't know what you're talking about
are there people that you would rather i
mean you you can't turn anyone away from
your restaurant but are there people
that you you think i don't want to go
over there and do a whole song and dance
with them you know if they come to you
i think i honor them when they come to
our restaurant now you know politics has
to stay out religion has to stay out i
think i don't get into a discussion with
them i mean obviously with politics here
in los angeles now where we are you know
yeah
i don't think it's uh
for me to do that you know when i feel
when people come to the restaurant
i'm here food to give them an experience
yes i know i'm gonna talk about their
politics you know if somebody is best
friends with trump and you know i have
people who are best friends with the
president then
you know what i don't gonna say you i
don't gonna serve you now
you know they're my friends so
maybe
right i mean maybe you cook their
salad a little bit something and they go
home
right i like the movie uh waiting which
i'm guessing you didn't see um and and
if people want to donate to meals on
wheels uh
i'm guessing yeah you can go on the
website meals okay send vincent miller
somewhere same vincent mills and wheels
and you're still involved in that and
that's the same
forever and we also have a big my wife
started it she's from ethiopia
she has an orphanage in ethiopia which
started with 25 kids and now we have 800
kids
and actually i'm going next friday to
austria
and they are going to honor me but i
said i don't want just an honor i don't
need a medal or some statue
they said well we donate 50 000 euros to
your charity so we're going to give 50
000 great euros to the school in
ethiopia in the countryside in ethiopia
where this school operates almost for
two months with that for the kids to eat
for the teachers salary electricity
outside of the city yeah oh wow that is
incredible and and where can people
donate to that
is uh uh dreams for future africa dreams
for future africa yeah um my wife is
from africa from ethiopia and there's a
little ethiopia here in los angeles and
do you guys ever eat down there on i
think it's uh yeah yeah yeah yeah
fairfax yeah a lot of it
yeah my mother-in-law is here
she bought two suitcases and i took him
out of the car and said what do you have
here and that body is just no
it's food oh wow really yeah
wow that's slightly insulting to you no
i love it i love it because she is so
excited and like we had it last night oh
yeah and yeah
yeah
slow cooked things and you know they
have like this chickpeas which they cook
with a lot of this bubble spices and
lentils and chicken in this onion
jalapeno sauce so
it's really really delicious food yeah
it they don't have a big variety right
what they do is very good they're
curry-ish there's yeah it's it's a
little bit like indian but without the
curry thing without
the yellow color and the the two
americans
when you go to restaurants when do
do chefs come over and pay their
respects i generally go to restaurants
where i have friends and where i know
them yeah so i think i wonder if they
get nervous to cook for you oh no i'm
easy
yeah you're welcome i'm really easy so i
can anyway yeah you know i remember i
used to go to billy wilder's house
billionaire rebounder you know
and one day we were in the kitchen and
audrey was cooking we were only like six
people or something like that
and this
other lady for the
told outre i said
aren't you nervous cooking for wolfgang
for wolfgang puck for wolfgang
and how do i look it just said hell no i
don't give a [ __ ] if he doesn't like it
he can flush it down the toilet he can
[ __ ] off yeah oh my gosh she was so
funny oh that's that's bold yeah totally
oh she had like that's wilder than i
would have thought oh my gosh she is
she was like yeah didn't say it in him
too both
austrians cynic cynical sense of humor
oh wow wow um what is there any when
you're just you just want to
whip something up you're home you're
hungry it's been a long day you just
want to
what do you do do you ever just throw
something together yeah i don't know i
just would make a grilled cheese
sandwich oh yeah we'd put a little
jalapeno in a little portion or a little
mustard
mustang
and have a good glass of red wine well
thank you so much thanks chef this was a
real pleasure my pleasure thanks for
listening guys
[Music]
so that happened
thank you i'm working i'm working on it
no that's not good he was more pocketed
he would say that's more german than
austria yes uh
it was like this it was more up it was
it was more like this upbeat so you just
got parked oh yeah you all got you all
got ear puck
that was very interesting it was um i
like at one point you compare him to
chef boyardee
and
sort of held my breath on that
really lucky
well he just wasn't listening to you i
think so he didn't listen to my janet
carson impression or he did he did i
think he like i think that was the one
yeah he did like that and he said are
you going to do me he was playful he was
sweet god i like that guy he opened up
so quickly
well the first thing was right away he
casually dropped that his father was a
terrorist that was funny right like you
go wait an actual terrorist
[Music]
his story is
incredible he's crazy incredible yeah
you also misunderstood yeah we were
disconnected for that part too because i
thought his i would i was confused as to
who the father was who was the terrorist
i thought it was the
by a lot i thought it was the biology no
because biological father was
from a different class and his family i
guess wouldn't let him
uh marry this woman that he hadn't that
he had impregnated right right that took
me i was behind on that and then i
missed that so not only as tragic as
that is to have your own father oh my
god not be in your life because your
mother happened to be from a different
class
as tragic as that is then on top of that
your mother
recovers from that recoups marries a new
guy who ends up being this evil person
he said the village like a crazy person
and he said it with such that that his
puckish
energy and delivery that i thought like
he was a crazy guy like the way in a
kind of a positive fun way like the way
our mother is or oh they're great you
know my mom is crazy don't get them
started yeah but he was it sounded like
dark crazy yeah like certified in in
like cuckoo evil yeah evil he he made
himself evil well we were talking about
this the other day too about struggle
like is struggle a necessary part of
success like a um
certainly an art dude people have to
struggle to be able to create i mean it
kept coming back to well why do you do
this it's one thing to like open spago
or mamasan or what you have like a great
success and i would imagine most chefs
um would would do that and then like
maintain that restaurant and or maybe
open another one or but he has tons i
know i would yeah yeah
i had 27 restaurants throughout the
country and i had my name on frozen
pizza and and i had as much money as he
does i i mean i don't like admitting
this about myself but i'm pretty sure
that i would just coast and you know
yeah and sit around and collect money i
mean i'm sure i would still cook because
i enjoy it but
i wouldn't i wouldn't be trying to open
the 28th restaurant i wouldn't be
pushing like that i know but it's i yeah
but it was that but i also didn't have a
stepfather who uh told me i was
worthless
he had several people in his life
men who would say said he was some
version of he's worthless and you're
good for nothing oh god it was so
infuriating too and his stepfather when
he said he talked about how his
stepfather took credit uh for his
success
as if that guy couldn't have come across
as a bigger [ __ ] i know and how how
did he restrain himself from attacking
him and just the things
that his sisters were still stuck there
and and and how he was helped by save
the children when he was young and now
he has given back to that organization
he's this big benefactor now oh that was
so moving it was it's just it it was
like a cinematic i know story his life
story i know starring uh christophe
waltz
i would imagine and the fact that he was
almost lost he was so pushed around by
these abusive people by his boss by his
stepfather
abandoned by that he was at one point in
his life this like buoyant
like uber successful
puckish man was at one point on a bridge
contemplating
killing himself i know like oh my god
what if he had and how much the
we would have lost you know i know what
a lesson i hope
anyone listening to to that um who who
had
maybe going through a dark time
god i hope i hope they they took from
that yeah he really is an inspiration
yeah
i wonder what the thing was that
prevented him from doing it you know
jumping there must have been i didn't
want to poke too much um though he was
so forthcoming i didn't want to but
still like yeah what was that thing
there was something in him that was
saying i'm gonna be able to live good
thing yeah i'm gonna be able to
contribute but you're right that's where
that drive comes from like i'm gonna if
i'm gonna do this if i'm gonna get off
this bridge go back down and deal with
this bastard who's like making me
you know questioning how i peel potatoes
uh i'm gonna really i'm gonna make it
count and he did he even said that i'm
gonna i'm gonna go back and show my
stepfather
and by by getting a mercedes i was so
curious i know what his guilty pleasure
right now was in terms of eating
and uh
and he was like it's got chocolate it's
65 to 70 percent minimum but it's like
that's not a guilty pleasure so he has
no guilty pleasure no it doesn't sound
yeah you just said pleasures
yeah and i then i felt immediately um
self-conscious for having asked that you
know like do you like reese's pieces or
what is yours by the way no i'm not
yours wait your your go-to snack food is
peanut butter m m's right
i mean peanut butter no that that's my
snack food we're going
but but if i could have one candy for
the rest of my life it would be peanut m
ms i think it's the most versatile
um well-rounded single candy that exists
so he doesn't have any guilty pleasures
unfortunately he just has and he no the
the smell of his wife's potato chips oh
yeah tries him crazy he hates the smell
of chips no
it doesn't get him going yeah uh he
hates potato he hates the peanut butter
the smell of peanut butter interesting
ah that is interesting i guess when
you're used to such fine fine cuisine
things that we take for granted also in
part of our lives well all start to
smell weird and fake and also
specifically with peanut butter that may
be more of an american thing or maybe he
must not have grown up with that i mean
think about we've known peanut butter
since we were little that's just
something that we take it might be a
very offensive smell if it's a newer
smell to you and you combine it with
yeah like you said just yeah and it was
a pleasure to meet them and so many and
what a great what a charitable goodbye i
know i know i know please visit those
charities and and he talked about them
in a way that was not at all
self-aggrandizing it was
i think it was so charming that he he's
still into improving
he's still in it he's really still in it
what an impressive person i'm so so
grateful that i got to talk to him and
and that he made that decision on the
bridge that day
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
i wonder if wolfgang puck ever asked
people to on yelp to say if if you like
samir give a five star review we're
available on apple podcast spotify
google podcast and every major listening
app as well as wondering.com life is
short is hosted by me justin long it's
produced by christian long and megan
monaco senior producer is michelle lanz
executive produced by marshall louis and
ernan lopez for wondering
well i like having the fellas over
well i like
yeah well it's weird i like having the
fellas over
and
we love having pizzas at this at 2 a.m
and so i said
well i got the pieces from wolfgang
i got a bunch of pizzas in the freezer
well why don't you tell me this i will
mix a pizza in a vape where you can
freeze it and then bring it out when
your friends are over for the poker
[Laughter]
well wolf
i'll tell you what you should do i'll
take it a step further you should sell
them in the stores
and be weird wouldn't it every wild if
you sold them in the stores
and for generations people would know
your name
long after you're dead
long after you're dead they know the
name wolfgang puck that's weird wine
stuff
and i gave you the idea
but i will say you could give me credit
one day on a
radio show
on a radio show
i don't know what they'll call it in the
future
you